في دراسه سواها كانت عن الشبكه العصبيه
فحطوا
[موسيقى]
وقدروا يعرفوا هو ايش يفكر فيه بنسبه 80%
الذكاء الاصطناعي بدون ما يتكلم
ماشي اخرج انا عايز اعرف هي بتفكر ماشي
زعلانه مني ولا ماشي اخرج ما تخرجش
انما لو عندي لو عندي وهي عندها مش
محتاجين نتكلم اه يا حبيبتي انت مش عايز
اخرج النهارده ههه فانا مستني تكنولوجي
تيجي بصراحه ههه
اهلا هذا فنجان من ثمانيه وانا عبد الرحمن
ابو مالح انا خائف والكل
خايف الذكاء الاصطناعي وما هو مستقبل
البشريه
المشكله لما نقول مستقبل البشريه
يجيك بال الناس انه بعيد
والمصيبه انه قريب شفت الاله المعلمه في
خانه اكاديمي اليوم طلعت وادركت اننا ما
نحتاج مدرسين من اليوم مو بعد سنوات لا من
اليوم وتقرا عن وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
تستثمر في الذكاء الاصطناعي والروبوتات
فاتخيل البوستن داينامك مثلا مع ذكاء
اصطناعي وبعدها لن نحتاج لجيش بشري
وتشوف بنفسك قدره تشاد جي بي تي تعرف ان
العالم اللي نعرفه اليوم ما يشبه الامس
تسال العلماء في الذكاء الاصطناعي
والباحثين والعاملين فيه يتفقون ان
الوظائف اغلبها ما بيكون لها حاجه خلال
السنوات القليله القادمه فالاسئله كيف
تتفاعل الحكومات مع الموضوع لان الشركات
تفاعلت فصل الموظفين بالمئات والالاف من
الشركات موجود واستبدالهم بالاعلى في حلول
ان الحكومات تعطي فلوس للناس بدون ما
يشتغلون وهذا المعروف بالضمان الاجتماعي
او يونيفرسال انكم بس لو الناس اخذت فلوس
وهي فاضيه
كيف بتحقق ذاتها ايش تسوي اسئله كل
اجوبتها مخيفه لكن الضيف يتفق معي على كل
التحديات لكنه يؤمن باننا بنلقى حل ضيفي
الدكتور عمرو عوض الله مؤسس عده شركات
احدثها منافسه لشركه اوبن اي اي اسمها
بكتابه الحلقه سريعه مره ممتعه مره مضحكه
مره مفيده مره وما منعناها من الاستزاده
الا الوقت الضيق لكن بحول الله بسجل حلقه
ثانيه قريبا وبتكون برضو فيه حلقات متنوعه
ومتعدده عن الذكاء الاصطناعي خلال
الاسابيع والاشهر القادمه ليه
لان هذا التحول هو تحول مهول في تاريخ
البشريه يقول رئيس جوجل انه اهم من التحول
اللي حصل بالبشر عندما اكتشف الانسان
النار
قبل ان نبدا
بحتاج هنا مساعدتكم فساعدوني بالوصول الى
شخصيات مثيره وباحثه في مجال الذكاء
الاصطناعي في اي دوله لكن المهم انه يتحدث
العربيه راسلونا على بريد البرنامج فنجان
ثمانيه
اما الان
لنبدا قديش صعب العربي في الذكاء
الاصطناعي واللي ما يفرق
صعب العربي علي على الذكاء الاصطناعي لا
لا ما يفرقش هو نفس يعني نفس الطرق بس
محتاج محتاج
تدريبنجاء الصناعي ندربه على كتب عربي
اكتر كلام عربي اكتر بس خلاص يعني بعد ما
ندربه محتاجين نعمل حاجه مختلفه يعني ما
هي دي فكره ده جمال الصناعي يعني هو مش زي
البرمجه
الذكاء الاصطناعي هو بيتعلم براحته يعني
انت بتول اه لوحده
امثله من الحاجه اللي انت عايزه تتعلم
عليها وهو بيفهمها حاجه حاجه يعني
تهبل
خالص والله
احنا هنعمل حاجات في العالم عمرنا هنعرف
نلاقي علاج لامراض عمرنا ما كان ممكن
نلاقي علاج لها لان ذكاء الاصطناعي بيف
احسن منها وهيقدر هيقدر
انا بحاول اتكلم العربي فاهم فبياخدني
شويه هيقدر يعمل سيرش في البحث في المجال
بتاع الاوبشنز الاختيارات الموجوده عشان
نلاقي الاختيار الصح يقدر يعالج المرض ده
اسرع مننا بكثير يعني احنا بني ادمين
بناخد وقت الذكاء الاصطناعي ما بينامش صح
طول الليل والنهار وعمال يدور وما يغلط
بيغلط بيغلط ما يكرر الخطا صح دي الفكره
يكون يعني مع الوقت طبيب ما يغلط
انما الطبيب لو علمته ما تعملش كده
في الحديث بعدين مراتي عليه يوم العمليه
ما هيغلط ثاني الراجل بني ادم يعني
بس اذا انت مبسوط بس معناه انه عندي مليون
طبيب صرعات على العمل ممكن يكلف
احنا بدانا
الحاره ههه
انت اعطيتني وقت قليل جدا انا لازم اشتغل
انت بدات على طول اه ما هي هو ده يعني
الحاجه الايجابيه ان احنا فعلا هنقدر نعمل
حاجات عمرنا ما كنا نقدر نعملها قبل كده
بسرعه وبدقه
بجوده اعلى من عمرنا ما كنا نقدر نعمل قبل
كده انما اللي هيحصل فعلا ان
هيبقى في وظائف كثيره قوي هيحصل لها تغيير
في العالم كله وده مش اول حاجه يعني البني
ادمين احنا عندنا قابليه ان احنا نقادات
نتغير للوضع الجديد اللي احنا فيه يعني
مثلا ايه في الثوره الصناعيه الثاره
الصناعيه قبل ما تحصل عشان واحد يلبس ثوب
جميل زي التوب اللي انا لابسه وانت لابسه
داون كان لازم يروح والحق يلم القطن
بايديهم بايديهم وبعد ما ياخدوا الحكم
يقعدوا يعملوا القطن
فتله فتله ههه وبعد فتله فتله يحطوا جنب
بعض عشان يعملوا القماش وبعدين في الاخر
يجي الترزي بقى يقطع القماشه ويعمل ويعمل
التوب الثوره صناعه جت
كل الناس دي شغلها راح والناس كانت في
الشوارع بتعمل مظاهرات شغلنا مهم ازاي
تعمله فينا كده انما الدرس الاساسي
ايفشنسي ان احنا نقدر نعمل حاجه بقدره
انتاجيه عاليه لما بتحصل ما فيش حاجه تقف
قدامها
القدر الانتاجيه دايما هتكسب ان انا ابني
عماره كبيره
وخلصها في شهر بدل ما ابنيها بخمس سنين
لما كان عندي دكتور يقدر يشخص نفس المرض
بطريقه ميه في الميه بسرعه جدا ويعملها في
العالم كله كل واحد يبقى عنده الايباد
بتاعه يقدر يشخص يعني يكون واحد فقير في
الهند مع الايباد يقول له انت عندك المرض
وتاخد دواء ايه ده حاجه جميله جدا بيكون
افضل الطبيب في العالم
في اطباء كثيره هيخسروا شغلهم انما اننا
وعندي ثقه فيه ان احنا كان بني ادمين
هنتغير وهيبقى لنا شغلات جديده هتطلع بس
ايه رايك انه انت حطيت مثال الثوره
الصناعيه ايوه بس المشكله انه مثلا فيه
سندار بتشاي ايوه
الذكاء الاصطناعي الي وصلنا له اليوم اشبه
باكتشاف الانسان للنار صح فما كان يقول ما
كانت الثوره الصناعيه فالتحول اكثر
الصناعيه صح انا وحتى لو بتاخذ ثوره
صناعيه فهو حتى اسرع من الثرى الصناعي فما
يمدينا تصورك عن ان البشريه بتكون وضعها
تمام
انا انا اوبتيمست انا انا كشخصيه عمرو
دياب متفائل انا عمرو دايما متفائل ان
احنا ربنا معنا ان شاء الله
ولو بصيت يعني لو بصيت على التاريخ بتاع
البشريه
دايما كنا كده في الاول يعني النار لما
طلع في الاول ما كنا خايفين منها يعني اول
واحد عمل
بس النار دي هي اللي خلينا معها في نطبخ
الاكل والاكل ده هو اللي خلى مقيمه يكبر
وخلينا هتتطور
فالنار كانت مفيده جدا بالنسبه لنا بطريقه
عمرها ما حصلت في مستقبل البشريه قبل كده
ومن غير النهار ما كناش نبقى يعني رواد
العالم زي ما احنا كان غوريلات هم بقوا
الروايات العالم ولا الاسود ولا حد ثاني
يعني فالنار في الاخر كانت حاجه ايجابيه
اه في القهوه كنا خايفين من النار انما
لما عرفنا ازاي نستعمل النار صح ونحط
حواليها البرامترز القوانين الصح النهارده
بقى مفيده جدا فانا معه ان هو فعلا الثوره
الذكاء الاصطناعي دي اكبر من الثوره
الصناعيه الثوره الصناعيه حاجه صغيره ان
احنا كنا بنعمل حاجه بايدينا دلوقتي
بنعملها بالمكنه ده دي حاجه بعقلانه هنقدر
نطورها وهيبقى زينا وبنفكر بطريقه زينا
اسرع بكثير
احسن بكثير عمرها ما تنام ارخص بكتير
هنكتشف حلول لمشاكل بشريه كتيره الاكل
احنا عندنا مشكله في الاكل احنا مش عارفين
هنزرع اكل في البني ادمين ازاي في العالم
دلوقتي
اكل يعني لما تشوف اللحوم المصنعه بجوده
عاليه
يعني الحين بسوي حركه بسويها اني مقاطعك
علشان نكسب الوقت
لا اطباء اللي هم التشخيص الاطباء اللي هم
السيرجي بس حتى محتاجينهم
بس عندك حق انا عملت عمليه بتعمل نظر
العمليه كانت كلها روبوت الدكتور بس بس
كده واقف
ههه اي حد عمل لك على الموضوع ده سبحان
الله فعندك الان الاطباء بيطلعوا من مات
محاسبين ما نحتاج محاسبين محامين ما نحتاج
محامين
جيش بشر ما نحتاج
الدفاع ياخد الرصاص ويكمل تخيل بوستنمك
يصير ذكي
يعني
اللي هو الذكاء الاصطناعي بتاع النظر ان
هو يقدر يقرا السيجنس التانيه مش السجن
الضوئيه السجن الضوئيه اللي احنا بنشوفها
بعينينا لا بيقرا بيقرا الواي فاي سجنال
ازاي الواي فاي سجن خبط التحدي هنا وبعدين
القزاز هنا يعرف ان في واحد الحته دي يعني
بيشوف وراء الحيطه ههه نقطه واذا ما فرقت
معك ابوي
وممكن تسويه من مواد غير قابله
كمان ما نحتاج
معلمين
اشباقي يعني
في الاول
انت بتروح عند اولادي بيكتب لك اي كود
تقول له اكتب لي
خلاص لا المبرمجين اول حاجه هتروح فكيف
متفائل فمتفائل حاجتين اول حاجه
عايزه اكرر ان احنا كبني ادمين بالادابس
يعني اللي اخترع النار في الاول ده وشافه
ما عرفش اللي هيبقى النهارده كمان 10,000
سنه بعد ما اخترع النار في الجمال ده كله
بسبب النار
يا بني ادمين صعب علينا
ان احنا نتوقع المستقبل بيبقى صعب انما
اللي احنا عارفينه من التاريخ بتاعنا ان
احنا بنعرف نغير ان احنا بنعرف نلاقي شغل
جديد غير الشغل اللي كنا بنعمله قبل كده
في المجال الجديد في الجو الجديد اللي
احنا فيه فده اللي بيديني تفاعل ان احنا
ان انا واثق فينا كبني ادمين ان احنا كلنا
مع بعض هنعرف نقادات بس في نفس الوقت لازم
عندنا قوانين وعندنا طريقه نخلي النار في
الحاله دي الاي يستخدم في الحاجات الصح مش
الحاجات غلط ده انا خايف منه لان الاي او
ممكن حاجات غلط هنتكلم في الموضوع ده بعد
كده في موضوع كده
الناس اللي هي في شغلها المحامي اللي هو
الدكتور اللي هو يعني دكتور اللي هو يعني
يعقوب مجدي يعقوب ده يعني جينيس يعني يعني
شايف عمليات جديده في القلب ممكن تعمل ما
حدش كان بيفكر فيها مجدي هاقوم مصري انا
سعودي مصري امريكا بكل بكل الناس في
العالم
فالناس اللي زي ده زي مجدي يعقوب او زي زي
نيوتن نيوتن ده كان يعني اينشتاين عبقري
نيوتن بالنسبه لي ده يعني ايه ده ازاي
واحد عمره ما شاف فيزيكس عمره ما شاف اي
حاجه شفته بتقع وقال لك قوانين الفيزياء
قوانين الجاذبيه ده حاجه يعني الناس اللي
زي كده هنحتاجها لسه يعني الناس اللي زي
كده هيبقى عندها جواز وكل حاجه مش مشكله
اي مش هيعرف يوصل لمستواهم الطفرات
الذكائيه دي متظاهرت في الموسيقى او اسمه
ايه بتاع
الناس دي هتبقى لها شهور بس طبعا المشكله
ان احنا يعني
99% الباقيين لازم حاجه من اثنين لازم
يتعلموا سكيل جديده شغله جديده احنا مش
عارفينها دلوقتي يعني مثلا زي ايه
الانستجرام
انت انت شغلتك انترفيوس دي موجوده من من
20 سنه
الاصطناعي يقدر تسوي بدونك بس لا في
الاموشمل انت عندك حق فعلا بس انا ممكن
اعمل ذكاء اصطناعي يعمل نفس دورك بس
التكنيك بتاعك يعني مثلا اوبرا من احدث
المتحدثين انا ممكن اعمل زي ويقلد طريقه
كلامها ويقلد الريش اعمل جديده فابرينا
هيطلع يعني كل شويه هيطلع واحد له ستايل
جديد الاستايل ده عمره كان موجود قبل كده
الذاكره الاصطناعي بيعرف يميكس سماع ماتش
يعرف موجود وستايل موجود يحطهم مع بعض
ويعمل ستايل جديد يعرف يعمل كده بس ما
ينفعش يعمل ستايل جديد عمر ما حد يفكر فيه
الطريقه بتاعه اوبرا الطريقه بتاعتك بتاع
الفنجان اللي خليتك مشهوره مختلفه ما هياش
ناس طريقه بتاعه اي حد تاني في السعوديه
كان بيعمل برنامج قبل كده الحاجات دي لسه
هيبقى فيها شغل الكرياتيفيتي اللي على
الليفل ده هيبقى فيها شغل في رايي فدي
الحاجه التانيه النقطه الرئيسيه بيئه يعني
عنده 10 سنين 20 سنه وطالعينه عايزين شغل
لازم تبقى حاجتين اول حاجه
لازم تتعلم ازاي تبقى في الحاجه اللي انت
هتنقيها هتبقى شغلتك انت ما ينفعش انت من
احسن
فانت هي في التمبر سانتيا هتبقى تعرف انه
90% هذول يتكلمون عن المليارات فنعمل فيهم
ايه بقى
هيحصل حاجه اسمها
يونيفرسالوري دي دي المرجحه انها تحصل انه
يصير زي الضمان الاجتماعي اللي الحكومه
تعطي فلوس بس ان كل الناس لازم الحكومه
ولازم الشركات اللي عندها الذكاء الصناعي
هتطلب كده لان الشركه يعني افرض انها
الشركه انا الشركه الصناعيه وببيع منتج
مهمين هيشتري منتج ده
ما هم الناس لو ما عنديش انا خمسين مليون
في السعوديه بيشتري مني المنتج بتاعي ههه
يبقى عندها فلوس عشان يعرفوا يشتروا
المنتج اللي الذكاء الاصطناعي بيعمله صح
فلازم ده اسمها
ناجح لازم السرقه دي تبقى كلوز فاللي
هيحصل من الشركات اللي هتنجح قوي جدا
الشركات الصناعي لازم هيدوا ضرائب اكتر
للدوله والدرايب الهيدول الدوله دي هتاخد
منها جزء يدوها للموظفين اللي مش لاقيين
شغل واللي مش هيلاقوا شغل عشان يعيشوا
حياه جميله نيرفانا هابي اللي عايز يروح
يتفسح في حته يتفسح اللي عايز يشتري حاجه
يشتريها عشان الفلوس دي ترجع تاني للذكاء
اللي بتعمل الفسحها واللي بتعمل المنتجات
واللي بتعمل الخدمات عشان يبدا القانونيه
يفضل يكمل بس تعرف انه في حاجتين هنا واحد
ان الحكومات تاخذ رايب من الشركات اللي
بتدخل فلوس بس هنا انت تتكلم عن مين عن
امريكا فقط لا لا كل الحكومات كيف تقدر
الحكومه السعوديه تاخذ ضريبه من جوجل
[ضحك]
عبر القارات الى الان يعني مثلا اليوم
احنا نسوي مثلا
كانت في فلوس تروح للاس تي سي او موبايلي
صارت تروح صح
تعمل ديل مع ابل تقول لهم لو عايزين في
الدوره بتاعتنا لازم تدفع الضريبه
الجوبليس اللي عندنا بسببكم طيب بتيجي
تقول ابل مثلا ولا جوجل انت البحرين ما
احتاجك
يروح جاي عمرو بقى بتاعه ويقول انا هديكي
ان شاء الله انا عندي دكتوره يعني هو كان
في جوجل هو الاختيار كثير قوي من التكنيكس
اللي اسمها ترانسفورمرز اللي بتخليني
انالايز اللانش بطريقه هو بصراحه
لا ده الهدف بتاعنا الهدف بتاعنا والهدف
العالم كله لازم يبقى عنده الهدف ده ان هو
عنده
اختيار ثاني غير ابل وجوجل وامازون
ومايكروسوفت لازم لان هو ما حصلش كده مش
هيبقى عنده
بالعربي تبقى ايه قوه
المفاوضات القوه المفاوضيه ان انت بقى
عندك الابر هاند العليا في المفاوضات ان
انت عندك اوب شن تاني لو ما عندكش اوبشن
ثاني
نتاقلم مع التغييرات ان شاء الله النار
اخذت عشره الاف سنه صح
بمقياس انت شفت مثلا في كورونا
الحكومات اثبتت انها ما تتاقلم بسرعه لا
السعوديه تقريبا
منظومه عالميه لان السعوديين
فتعاون الحكومات مع بعض وتطور الحكومات
وتاقلمها مع ان تتكلم الان عن اربع سنين
خمس سنين صح في كل التغيرات التكاسي
ما اثبت تاريخ ان الحكومات قادره على
التاقلم بهذه السرعه
فيبدو ان احنا التاريخ اثبت ان لما
الحكومات بيشوفوا البدايه بتاعه العك ههه
اقول عكس
ايه ده
يعني
يوم الصبح هيقوموا يعملوا قوانين جديده
فلا انا حاسس يعني عجين احنا
بنتاقلم بسرعه اول ما نشوف الدليل بنتاقلم
بسرعه
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
هيحصل بسرعه رهيبه ايش اللي حصل من بعد ما
اعلنت
من ناحيه التغييرات اريد الحكومه امريكا
امريكا امبارح اوريدي بداوا كانسل بداوا
لجنه لجنه
بتاع جوجل وعزمه بتاع مايكروسوفت
أناهم عندهم لازم نعمل هنعمل ايه في
الموضوع ده الناس
نحضر الموضوع ده الناس اللي تاخد الصوت
بتاعك وتعمله
اموال منه او تكلم البنك بتاعك وتاخذ منه
فلوس عشان صوتك زي ما يكون انت اللي تطلب
الفلوس القوانين بتاعتها ايه فالموضوع
يعني الموضوع فعلا يعني خلاص هم شافوا
اللي بيحصل لان بدا في امريكا فعلا يحصل
مشاكل جامده جدا يعني يعني كان في الاخبار
من حوالي اسبوعين واحده جالها مكالمه انا
خطفت بنتك انا بنتها كانت المكسيكي ام
مليون دولار على الاكونت انا هقتلك بنتك
قالت له طب اديني اثبات راح مكلها الحقيني
يا ماما انا محبوسه مع الراجل ده هيطلع
عين اهلي ويعمل ابعتي له فلوس بسرعه
ده قبل من الصوت البنت الحمد لله من حظ
امها ان البنت فعلا كانت في المكسيك بس
البنت كلمتها بعدها بكام ساعه عادي بتطمن
عليها امي هتلاقيه ده انت كنت لسه هبعت
الفلوس قالت لها انا كويسه وكل حاجه مفيش
حتى اعلان بايدن الانتخابات كان برضه في
نسخه مزيفه انا شفتها فيعني
جدا جدا
فلازم فلازم يبقى عندنا بس اقول لك يعني
الحل بتاعها ايه الحاجات دي حاجتين اول
حاجه ان هيبقى عندنا قوانين لازم عندنا
قوانين تمنع الاستغلال السيء بنفس الطريقه
احنا قوانين يعني العربيات من العربيات
لما العربيات اكتشفت وطلعت كميه البني
ادمين اللي اتقتلت بالعربيات اكتر من اي
حاجه تانيه اكتر من اي حرب العالميه
الاولى والثانيه مع بعض الناس اللي مات من
العرب بسبب العربيات في الاول حتى لسه
لغايه دلوقتي
لغايه لما اكتشفنا ايه ده لو حطينا حزام
ولازم الناس تلبس حزام ده بيقلل نسبه
الوفاه 70% وحطينا ايرباج ده اروح مقالب
كمان ب 20% وحطينا كاميرات السرعه ما
تزيدش عن كده ضيقه فالقوانين دي كلها
بتقلل الدمار بتاع التكنولوجي واحنا لازم
نعمل حكايه نفس الحكايه والحاجه التانيه
ان احنا بنقول لعربيه استخدامها الرئيسي
ايه ان انت تروح من حته الحته العربيه مش
استمع رئيس ان انت تروح في حته وتدوس 10
بني ادمين بالعربيه ههه يعني دي حاجه ممكن
تعملها صح انما القانون بيقولوا عملت كده
هنطلع هنحطك في السجن ونطلع وننفخك
في مجال الاي اي هينام نفس الحكايه هيبقى
في استخدامات معينه لو عملتها هتتنفخ لازم
كده لازم
فيها تحدي الفرق
التحدي ايش يصير انه يعني حتى نفس اللي
حصل مع
القنابل النوويه انه صار في ضبط لها بس
انه هذه كلها سواء السيارات ولا قنابل ولا
غيرها من الاسلحه الاشياء اللي ضبطها
العالم هي اشياء ما يعني اذا سويتها
بيكتشف العالم صح اللي انت سويته الذكاء
الاصطناعي انا اقدر اسوي كل هذا وما حد
يعرفني انا يعني تقدر اي حكومه انها تبدا
تستخدمها استخدام سيء بدون ما تقدر انت
تكتشف انهم جالسين يطوروا هذا الشيء صح صح
فالفروقات تختلف يعني لا صح عندك هي هي هو
في الاول في في مثالين جميل جدا من الماضي
انا دائما بحب ابص على الماضي ان انا ازاي
على الاقل اتحاول اتوقع المستقبل مع ان
المستقبل طبعا صعب جدا انما عندك حق في
موضوع
انرجي الثوره النوويه العالم فعلا جه مع
بعضه بس بعد ما امريكا استغلتها بطريقه
سخيفه مع اليابان يعني اليابان هيروشيما
80000 بني ادم وعياله وامهات في ظرف ثانيه
حاجه يعني رعب انا يعني عمري ما افكر
بحاجه يعني بزعل يعني بعيط لما بس بعد ما
حصل الحاجات دي جينا كعلم مع بعض قلنا لا
ده خطا جدا يعني دي قوه اكبر من ان احنا
فلازم نتفق مع بعض ان هي لا استخدامها
يبقى يعني لك قوانين والعالم كله اتفق
العالم كله فعلا اتفق يعني فعلا مثال جميل
بس طبعا القوه النوويه صعب ان اي حد يلاقي
تكنولوجي دي صعب ان هو لاقي المواد اللي
مش زي الذكاء الصناعي يعني عامل داونلود
وخلاص يعني موجود كل حاجه
تطلب من النظام انما عمله في العالم كله
اتفقوا مع بعضه ان احنا مش هنسمح مش ده
السنساخ البشري والتعديل البشري مش تعديل
مسموح به شويه صغيرين بس الانساخ يعني ان
انا اعمل منك مش مسموح وفعلا الصيني اتفقت
وامريكا اتفقوا كل الدول الكبيره اتفقنا
واتفقوا مع بعض وفعلا حصلت بطريقه كويسه
فده اجزاء جميل وده اقرب شويه لان
التكنولوجي بتاعته صعبه شويه مش بس مش زي
نيوكلير بس تكتب
تلقى ناس تسويها لنفسها على نفسها بس بس
يعني اجهزه طبعا
في اليابان في الصين عملت
السجنشوف الشمس ثاني خلاص لان البلاد مع
بعض فلازم يبقى عندنا القوانين دي اللي هي
لو حد هستخدم التكنولوجيا دي بطريقه سيئه
لا الدول كلها زي يعني هيبقى اتحاد الدولي
كله هيجي عليهم لان لو مفيش كده فعلا ممكن
تستخدم بطريقه بس خلينا نتخيل انا احس
الامثله حلوه الان مثلا مصر
الان فيها ازمه اقتصاديه حتى تتركيها يعني
كيف الاقتصاد يشتغل والحكومه لا تستطيع
انها تدفع لهم فلوس لان مثلا يقول فيديو
الغنيه مثلا زي السعوديه ودول الخليج ممكن
يعني
[موسيقى]
انا مش عايز اتكلم في السياسه قوي
بس اقول لك يعني انسى مصر يعني دوله اكس
اوكي يعني دوله
شويه بس انا بتكلم عن دوله
اكس دي لو هم خدوا ضرائب صح ده هم فعلا
يعني امريكا اللي مخلي امريكا امريكا
بصراحه الضرائب
يعني ده العام ده العب من انا ده من اقوى
المخابرات اللي في العالم بتاع الار اس
عندهم عندهم البنوك العالم كلها لو انا
عندي بنك في السعوديه في الاي ار اس
وامريكا عارفين انا عندي بنك هنا وعارفين
قد ايه ولو ما علي يجيبوني وينفخوني ههه
ده كان من اشهر المافيا اللي في امريكا
اشهر المافيا كان بيتاجر في المخدرات
وبيتاجر في الستات وبيتاجر في كل حاجه له
نفسه فيه وبيقتل اللفت شمال ويمين جابوه
في الاخر السجن من ضرايب
ما يعرفوش يجيبوه من اي حاجه جابوهم من
ضرايب
الدرس هنا ايه ان البلاد كلها لازم تبقى
خبره خبره خبره في تجميع الضرائب لان
هيحصل في المستقبل ان البيزنس والشركات
عالميه زي جوجل او شركه لوكال هنا زي زي
مثلا رش بنك ولازم يدفعوا الضرائب عليهم
لان الضرايب اللي عليهم دي هي اللي هترجع
كدخل للدوله يقدروا يدو
يعني في دوله اكس دي اللي احنا بنتكلم
عليها في في الحكومه حوالي عشرين واحد
عشرين مليون واحد بيشتغل بالحكومه من 20
مليون واحد الحكومه دول الانتاجيه بصراحه
يعني هم هم
بس بيروحوا يقعدوا في المكتب كده ازيك
عامل ايه
طيب وفي الاخر يبقى عمل ايه دقيقتين شغل
يمكن ولا حاجه فهما
فاحنا لازم محتاجين كده ده احنا محتاجينه
لازم يبقى عندنا الضرائب احسن والا مش
هنقدر نسستان مش هنقدر نكمل في بس
الانسان اصلا ما يبغى الفلوس
دي المشكله اللي انا خايف منها فعلا بجد
يعني انت لو سالتني انت خايف الناس يبقى
عندها لا انا حاسه هيبقى في نيرفانا انا
حاسس ان في ناس اكثر كثير ما عندها دخل
يجيب اللي هم عايزينه ويتفسحوا زي ما هم
عايزين يعني عندي
جدا اوبتوميستيك
بالعربي تبقى ايه متفائل جدا متفائل جدا
ان الناس عندها فلوس عايزاه بسبب بسبب
الثوره الذكاء الصناعي اللي انا خايف منه
انها ان هيبقى في
فرص عمل قليله جدا
البني ادم عايز يشتغل ليه بسبب من سببين
السبب الاولاني ان هو محتاج فلوس بس السبب
الحقيقي ان هو محتاج يبقى له معنى انا ليه
موجود في كوكب الارض ده يا ربي يعني ما
انا موجود عشان اعمل حاجه حلوه عشان لما
اسيبك الارضيه ربنا وعملت حاجه كويسه مش
بس جبت عيلين وخلاص يعني عملت حاجه اكتر
من كده يعني فلما ما كانش فيه فرص موجوده
حتى فرص خيريه اننا ناخد بالنا من كبار او
ناخد بالنا من البيئه او ناخد لازم يبقى
فيه فرص تخلي الناس تشتغل عشان يبقوا
عندهم رضا ان انا فعلا قضيت دوري وانما مش
بس مش واخذ فلوس عربيات واتفسح في السحره
واعمل خمسات بيسموه ايه غرزات وخمسات ومش
عارفين
يعني يعني من الدول الغنيه جدا سويسرا
جميل قوي عندنا ان احنا عندنا الايمان ده
عشان كده
بس بس لازم يبقى معاها ان احنا فعلا عندنا
الرضا والرضا بيجي منين الرضا بيجي ان انا
مش خايف على اكلي مش خايف على ااا
السكيورتي السيفتي بتاعتي السيفتي بالعربي
مش خايف الامان انا كويس وبعرف كويس واخد
بالي من عيالي دي حاجه والحاجه الثانيه ان
انا
عندي حاجه بعملها ان انا مبسوط ان انا بدي
للعالم حاجه اكتر ده اللي انا خايف منه
لان احنا ما يبقاش عندنا كفايه من ده مش
عارف بقى دي حلها ايه يعني انا عايز افكر
مع بعض في الحلقه الجايه ان شاء الله
هنعمل جزء ثاني ههه يبقى تفكير مع بعض ايه
الحاجه اللي ممكن نعملها تساعد تحل
المشكله دي ايه لان مشكله في جائزه العيد
يعني اخر يومين خلاص يعني اختلف الاوقات
النوم
بيخافوا من ايه لان احسن طريقه ان احنا
نتحكم في بني ادمين يعني ايه رئيس دوله
هيقول لك دي احسن طريقه تتحكم في الادمين
انت خوفهم من حاجه
تخوفهم تقول لهم اه الدوله التانيه هتهجم
علينا لازم انت تقفوا معايا وكله ورايا يا
ريس عشان اقدر ادافع عنكم او في حاله
ترامب او المكسيكان هينط فوق السور عالي
عشان ما احنا عندنا طائرات يا عم وعندنا
الفكره بس بس في ناس كثير صدقوه وفعلا
ترامب هيجي لازم
ايه الحاجات اللي بتخوف الناس بعدين يحطوا
بقى اعلانات ويحطوا مسجز على شخص الواحد
مو على الكل يعرف ايش يخوفك
تيك توك ويوتيوب وفيسبوك ده اللي بيعملوه
عشان الاند يعني لما تقلب التيك توك اللي
بعده ده طب ما هو نقى ازاي الفيديو اللي
بعد ده تيك توك جوه عندهم افاتار منك
الكابي اللي منك دي بتفكر زيك عارفه انت
بتحب ايه عارف انت
بتكلك على ايه عارف الفيديو ده بيجي اه
بتروح معديه على طول يبقى انت مش بتحب
الحاجه دي اهو الفيديو ده بتقعد تشوف
مرجعه شوف الحاجات الجميله دي ههه
بعدين هو بقى يعمل ايه انت بقى اوف لاين
انت نايم ولا مش عارف ايه هو بقى عمال
يشتغل مع الافاتار ده يدي له حاجات تانيه
اديله حاجات ثانيه ويشوف الافاتار ده بيحب
ايه وما بيحبش ايه لما انت لما تيجي
خلاص فالايه في الانتخابات هيبقى نفس
الحكايه ان انا هيبقى الانتخابات الجايه
هيبقى عندنا كلنا ايه اي بنستخدمه لكل
شخصيه في الوطن نعرف الشخصيه دي بتحب ايه
ما بتحبش ايه ونلعب مع جيمز مع الموديل
داون نلعب معه مليون طريقه قصه القصه
الاولانيه القصه التانيه القصه الثالثه
لغايه ما نلاقي قصتين اللي دايما بيسمعوها
ده ده احسن ريس في العالم ده انا لازم ده
يبقى رئيسي او الفوت ده احسن بوب في
العالم لازم البوت ده ومش هتبقى عارف ان
انت بالضحك عليك مش هتبقى عارف
هتبقى هتبقى فاكر لما هو فعلا ده ده
القرار السليم صح فعشان كده لازم في
المستقبل لو عندي وقت اعمل شركه تانيه
هعملها او لو حد هنا الفكره دي يعملها
يعملها يبقى عندنا فيروس للحاجات دي يعني
زي ما عندنا انتي فيروس للصور في
الكمبيوتر لازم يبقى عندك انتي فيروس
للمسجس للفوس
ماسجسكس
لم اسمع صوتك على التليفون ويبقى كافي من
صوتك يطلع لك
ده مش هو ده ده ايه اه يا عم مش ده الكافي
اوه المسج دي خلي بالك في حد بيضحك عليك
دلوقتي ههه انت بتضحك عليك دلوقتي انت
بتطرطس ههه
فلازم عندنا حاجه تخيل اليوم انت اليوم
البشر هم اللي زي الاخبار وبتمشي على
العالم فما بالك لو كانت الاخبار مزيفه
على النطاق الصغير بالذكاء بالضبط بيصير
شيء مخيف جدا
بس برضو في دراسه سووها كانت عن قدره
الشبكه العصبيه
فحطوا
وقدروا يعرفوا هو ايش يفكر فيه بنسبه 80%
بدون ما يتكلم ايوه ايوه يا الله لا لا
مصيبه لا دي مش مصيبه خالص
ماشي اخرج انا عايز اعرف هي بتفكر ماشي
اخرج زعلانه مني ولا ماشي اخرج ما تخرجش
انما لو عندي لو عندي في دماغي وهي عندها
مش محتاجين نتكلم النهارده اه يا حبيبتي
انت مش عايزاني اخرج
ههه فانا مستني تكنولوجي جديد يجي بصراحه
ههه لا بس ده لان احنا بني ادمين عمرنا ما
نعرف نتكلم مع بعض يعني كلام بيوصل نص
الفكره كلام عمره ما بيوصل فكره كلها لو
انا فعلا عندي الاشاره العصبيه بتاعتي
بتعرف مع الشبكه العصبيه بتاعتك مباشره مش
عن طريق الكلام
المعنى هيوصل بالطريقه الصح مش هيبقى في
اختلاف في المعنى لان المعنى اللي عندي هو
اللي هيبقى المعنى اللي عندك
انت ما يعني في المجامله في هذه اللي تخلي
العلاقات الانسانيه
وكده يعني
مش عارفه عنها جوه هنا مش تشوفها يعني انت
بتعمل بلوك على النمر دي والهاف ده
فعلا عنده شركه اسمها نيورال لينك
دي بتاعتها
ان احنا في المستقبل احنا احنا بقينا
السوبر هيومنتس بسبب ده يعني انا لو انت
رجعت لمليون سنه فاتت مش مليون 900 سنه 50
سنه فاتت موجوده
او جدتك اللي كانوا عايش تقول له انا
دلوقتي اقدر اقول لك تعداد السكان في اي
في الدوله في العالم كم انا دلوقتي اقدر
اقول لك قوانين الثيرمودانامكس ايه رغم ان
انت عمرك
انا دلوقتي ممكن احل لك معادله
الريلاتيفتي
النسبيه نسبيه بتاعت اينشتاين قدامك
دلوقتي اقدر اتصل فيديو الان وببلاش انا
اقدر اي واحد في العالم من الحاجات
بتاعتني هنا في السعوديه جديد لازم تفتكر
لازم افتكر اسمك ولازم افتكر انت ابو مين
صحيح ابو احمد ابو علي انا عارف افتكر
اسمك لما بتجرب اسمك
فتخيل بقى ان انا معايا معظم الناس
بيعملوا كومنتاكس هنا ويحطوا الاسم ابو
علي ده ورا الاسم فتخيل بقى ان انت عندك
شيب في دماغك ها لما انا ابص لك على وشك
كده يطلع لي قدامي في جنبك كده جنب جنب
راسك يطلع لي ده اسمك كده ابو كده واخر
مره اتكلمت مع بعض على فكره اتكلمت على
فيلم الفلاني واتكلمت سالك على صفحه مامتك
وقال لك ان باباه عنده مشكله كل المعلومات
طالعه قدامك كده هنبقى سوبر هيما النمري
هنفتك
نحلل المعلومات بطريقه عمرنا ما كنا حلينا
في الماضي ففي كتاب اوي حلو عن الموضوع ده
اسمه هومو دياس هوم ده بيقول هيحصل لنا
هتهور ازاي احنا كان بني ادمين لما يبقى
عندنا شيبس في دماغنا انا انا اول ناس انا
لما جينا
قادم يعني لا لا شويه
بس عملها على القرود وفعلا وورونا اجزام
الفظيعه قرد قرد قاعد كده والقرد باص على
التلفزيون وعنده جيم بتاع التاك مان حلو
ياخد الايس كريم كده وراه الجوس والقرد
بيلعب الجيم لا اله الا الله
بعدين واحد ثاني في في ستانفورد زي ما انت
قلت اعملوا
له شاشه قدامه وفي شاشه وراها الشاشه اللي
قدامه يبص على الصوره يشوف صوره مثلا جمل
يروح هنا يقرا سوره الجمل من دماغه ويروح
طلع ورا الجمل
ازاي يعني يعني حاجه خرافيه يا الله ان
شاء الله هنعرف نقرا الاحلام مش نفسر
الاحلام نقرا الافلام هي تتفرج على الفيلم
بتاع الحلم ثاني يوم
وريني كده الفيلم بتاع اه ده كان فيلم رعب
قوي بلاش في حلقه في بلاك ميرور ده
الموضوع عشان تشوف الجانب السيء
لازم يعني لازم مسائل التليفون ممكن يبقى
تجسس لغايه ما عرفوا لا بروتيكشن ازاي
والاب دي تدي والاب دي دي والفلان الفلاني
يقدر يخش عندي
الصور بتاع هيبقى حاجات كده برضه
يعني على اللي انا كتبت الكتاب
يعني هو عنده اشكال معكم هو عنده تخوف جدا
اهو عنده افكار جامده شويه في وهو حاسس
بمخرج سيولد يعني هو هو مقتنع ان لو الاي
اي فعلا بقى قوي بالطريقه دين وايه حد
يقدر يقنع البني ادمين العاديين
بالفوت بتاعه او يبقى مكرس ملهاش لازمه
كنا
لازم عندك اي اي هو البلد لان الناس هتبقى
غبيه
يعني لما نقول
الضمان الاجتماعي والفكره هذه انه اعتمادا
على اي معيار اصلا فمين يعني وش الاشياء
الاساسيه للبشر للي في السعوديه تختلف عن
اللي في مصر انا اللي في امريكا تختلف
الاشياء الاساسيه عندهم
واذا هو عالمي عالمي على اي اساس واذا هو
متوسط متوسط الحياه هنا تختلف عن المتوسط
الحياه هناك فالتحديات فيها كثيره بس
تحديات كثيره لكن يبغى لها حلقه طويله بس
لاني مهتم جدا بقصتك بودي اعرف
انت يوم طلعت من مصر الى طلعت رحت
فانا انا مولود في مصر وبعدين والدي
الدكتور الله يرحمها
بس والدي كان دائما يقول لي عمرو لما تكبر
هتبقى دكتور في جامعه زيي هتبقى زيه وكان
الدرس
اقتصاد
تجاره واقتصاد
كان دايما يقول لي هتكبر تبقى بس هو مش
لازم يعني اقتصاد زيه بس
جامعه القاهره
بتاعي خلصت
الماجستير وبعدين رحت امريكا كان هدفي ان
انا ناخد وبعدين ارجع مصر بقى عشان ادرس
وكده يعني دكتور زي بابا يعني
الكورسات يديك كورسات يديك ازاي تعمل
بيزنس بلان ازاي تعمل
يعزم يعزم الناس
بتوع جوجل بتوع ياهو بتوع اول ستار في
الجامعه فبتشوف الناس الراجل ما عندوش
جناحه ما عندوش اللي عارف بيبقى عندهم
بتاعها كده على الاسهم احنا عندنا دي حلوه
ده بني ادمين زينا ما عندهمش زياده ما
عندهمش عين زياده فعلى طول بيديك طب انا
ممكن ابقى زي واحسن منهم كمان انا فبيشجعك
ان انت ممكن تبقى فانا بعد ما شفت كده من
ستانفورد قلت لا انسى بقى بابا عايزه ده
ههه انا عايز ابقى رائد اعمال اللحظه هذه
اللي تذكرها
كان في محاضره من المحاضرات وكان في سبيكر
من شركه مش فاكر اسمها ابدا كان صغير كان
عنده 22 سنه انا كان عندي وقتها 25 سنه
وهو اوريدي كان سي اي او واريدي عنده 1000
موظف وبيبيع يمين وشمال
دلوقتي عنده 22 سنه وبيعمل وانا مضيع وقتي
في الدراسه ههه ففي اللحظه دي انا ده اللي
انا عايز اعمله والحاجه الثانيه اللي انا
انا قلت لك من الحاجات المهمه جدا لينا
كلنا كبشر
يبقى انت لازمتك ايه يعني عملت ايه يعني
فانا بالنسبه لي دي حاجه جوايا
دايما حياتي ببصلها يعني انا دايما بفكر
كده لو انا مت بكره ايه اللي انا سبته
الحمد لله الست اربع عيال حاجه جميله
واشجع كل الناس هتجيب عيان ان انا عايز
تسيب اكثر من العيال ما هو العيال هيموتوا
بعد الشر يعني بس احنا هيموتوا في يوم من
الايام
نفتكر اسم عياله ولا نفتكر اسمه امه ولا
مراته بس فاكرين ابل وفاكرين ايفون الساتش
فظيع فانا ده اللي بيخليني انا يعني انا
بعد ما شفت ده الارث اللي انا عايز اسيبه
ان انا عايز اعمل شركات تحسن العالم
بطريقه جميله جدا بحيث ان انا بعد ما اموت
بسنين الناس تفتكرني بسبب الارث اللي انا
سبته ده
سيلفي شويه بس برضه انا عارف ان انا
الفائده اللي دي تعملها ان شاء الله ربنا
هيدينا ثواب عليها ونخش الجنه طيب فقررت
انك تبغى تطلع من ولا لا وبعدين
الدكتوراه لازم تبقى دكتور في الجامعه
ازاي يا بابا انا عملت فلوس اكثر من
عملتها طول عمرك ههه
حياك الله حياك الله بس هو قال لي لا لازم
تروح تخلص دي وانا فعلا كان جوايا العزيمه
فانا خلصت وانا شغال في قهوه
عملت البيج دي بارت تايم وخلصتها الحمد
لله
تلاقي المنتج تلاقي سعره موجود في اونلاين
في الحاجات الايه السباكس بتاعته
المواصفات بتاعته الصور بتاعته والحاجات
دي ازاي تكرار الويب للمعلومات دي يعني
الشركه بتاعتي ما شاء الله قعدت ياهو كم
سنه قعدت كتير قوي قعدت ثمان سنين من 2000
الى 2008 بس من سبب الرئيسيه انا قعدت ان
انا كنت عايز اخلص دكتوراه فانا في نفس
الوقت وبشتغل والحمد لله عرفت الاثنين
خلاص الدكتوره وبرده المجال بتاعي فيها
رساله الدكتوراه بتاعتي كانت حاجه اسمها
اكثر موفي بحبه وهو بتاع ده بقى الموضوع
الحلقه الجايه نتكلم في الموضوع اللي
بتحبه جدا
الاصطناعي هو العلاقه جامده على فكره
فعشان كده التخرج
معلش بقى خالص
ازاي ممكن استعملها ان احنا نخلي السوفت
وير والابلكيشن تمشي موجودين بحيث بتاعنا
يبقى قليل يبقى سريعه يبقى الاستجابه
سريعه وفعلا بقى كل الشركات بتعمل كده
دلوقتي فده الدكتوراه بتاعتي يعني
2008 بعدين بدات شركه كادرا شركه كادرا
الحمد لله كبرت لغايه لما راحت النيورك
كانت الفكره الاساسيه
تحليل المعلومات تحليل المعلومات الكبيره
ازاي تعمل تحليل المعلومات على على المجال
الكبير معلومات كثيره يعني كان معظم
الداتا عندنا قواعد البيانات اللي كانت
عندنا زي اوركل وكده ما كانوش يسكيل
باريوال يعني ما ينفعش يكبروا الحجم كبير
فاحنا كنا اول شركه في العالم عرفت تعمل
الحكايه يعني تخلي الكميه المعلومات اللي
جوه السيستم تكبر وناجحه جدا في السعوديه
على فكره من دول الناجحه فيها جدا كلا
السعوديه في العالم كله في العالم كله
في اخرها عملنا في اخر لسه مشغلها بس
عملنا اللي هو
ما اعرفش بالعربي نزلت في الاسواق في
البورصه
في احلى احلى لحظات في حياتي لحظه
ولاده ابني او بنتي انا عندي ولد وثلاث
بنات لحظه زواجك طبعا طبعا
حاجه فظيعه
الشعور
بتاعك بيدوك شاكوش وتضرب جرس كده قدامك
تمسك ضرب الجرس معناها شركتك بقى خلاص بقى
نفس الشعور بالضبط حاجه عارف الشيفرز كده
عارف اشعارات كده في الجسم كله كان شعور
فظيع نفسي اكرره ثاني ان شاء الله
وبعدين بعد ستوب ماركت بسنتين في شركه جت
اسمها كيكي ار دي من اكبر شركات في العالم
اشترت كلاود كلها فور فايف
بس
ممتاز طلعت منها رحت جوجل
بعد بعد بعد
كلودرا رحت جوجل سنتين كنت الفايس برزنت
اوف ديبر ريليشنز لجو كلاود وكتير بيجي لي
السؤال ليه رحت جوجل يعني ليه ما عملتش
شركه تانيه على طول
ثلاث حاجات اول حاجه انك تعمل الشركه دي
حاجه صعبه جدا ده استرا
انا كنت بعيط كل شهرين مره
انك تعمل الشركه دي حاجه صعبه جدا جدا
لازم تكون مستعجله نفسيا يعني زي الجواز
بالظبط ما هو الجواز برده في الجواز ههه
ان معون ابريج احنا سعداء ونبرز بس
لازم لازم تبقى مستحمل فانا انك تبدا
استارت لازم تبقى مستعد نفسيا زي نفس
الاناجي لو طلقت ما بتعرفش تتجوز على طول
يعني استنى سنتين بعدين اتجوز ههه عشان
نفسيا تبقى مستعد ان شاء الله فهي نفس
الفكره بالظبط فانا قلت لا لازم اريح شويه
قبل ما ابدا الشركه الثانيه دي اول حاجه
ثاني حاجه ان انا كنت فيري فوك يعني مركز
جدا على المجال الشغل بتاع اللي هو تحليل
المعلومات الكبيره ده كان كل اللي انا
مركز عليه مكنتش نشوف بقى اللي بيحصل في
الذكاء الاصطناعي واللي بيحصل في في
الموبايل جي واللي بيحصل في
اللي هو العالم الافتراضي بقى الحاجات دي
فلازم لما تبدا شركه جديده تبريك يعني
فرصه ان انا لا انا عايز ابعد من اللي انا
كنت مركز عليه واشوف ايه اللي بيحصل عشان
انقي الحاجه الجديده اللي فعلا هتبقى هي
المستقبل
من احسن الاماكن اللي تشوف فيها الحاجات
فانا كنت عندي خطه
الحمد لله جالي الرول بتاعي وكان فعلا
اختيار موفق وفعلا لما رحت
شفتها بعيني لا لا ايه ده ده واضح ان ده
المستقبل فكان ده ثاني حاجه ثالث حاجه ان
انا انما تبدا شركه جديده هيبقى معاك
هتلاقي
ان انت تبقى في جوجل او في مايكروسوفت ان
هم يبداوا معاك الحكايه وفعلا ده اللي حصل
بالظبط يعني كل ثلاثه
باكستانيين هم الاثنين مسلمين احنا الشركه
الرياضه المسلمين الحمد لله فدي حاجه انا
فخور بيها
ممتازين ممتازين
للمعلومات الخاصه للشركات فالفكره
ايه ان احنا دلوقتي واساله سؤال وحلو جميل
وكل حاجه بس لما بيجاوبني بيجاوبني
المعلومات الموجوده على الويب يعني
الموجوده في الباب لو انا شركه مثلا بتاعه
الاستثمار اوكي وعندي كل
الريبورتس بالعربي تبقى ايه ههه في مصر
بنور البرتقال عن التقارير اللي انا
كاتبها ليه استثمر هنا ليه ما استثمرش هنا
ممكن اخد كل تقارير دي بقى واحطها جوه
الشاتيه
التقارير بتاعتي وعامل معاكم حديث اقول له
اقول له بتاعي انا اخر مره لما بصيت على
شركه جايه لي واحد من اسبانيا
ليه قلت له لا يروح قال لك انت قلت له لا
عشان كده وكده اه قل لي قل لي معلومات
زياده عن نمره 2 ده ليه ليه قلت كده روح
شارع اوه طب لو كان ده جاي من
برازيل بدل اسبانيا كنت هدي له فلوس ولا
لا هيقول لك انت ممكن بس في شريكه التاني
في نفس الشركه احنا عندنا الريبورت بتاعه
وهو كان بيقول المفروض ندي له فلوس وده
الاسباب ليه
المعلومات بتاعتك كانها موظف معاك في
الشركه ههه المعلومات بتاعتك بقت معاك في
الشركه فاكر كل حاجه فاكر كل حاجه اي حد
عملها في الشركه اي حد ولا تصير عندك نسخه
منها لا
[موسيقى]
السنه اللي فاتت فظيعه فظيع اسمه منجره
منجاره ام او يو ان جي اي ار او
منجرد لما تاخده هو حقنه بتاخده في البطن
كده سهله يعني
ما تجوعش
ما تحسش بجوع
يعني انا ما عنديش اي
مش عايز اكله
لما احب اكل اكل عشان انا فعلا دلوقتي
جعان لازم اخد شويه اكل صغيرين كده وخلاص
الحمد لله
بعد ما خدته نزل حوالي 30 كيلو 40 كيلو من
غير فرق ما فيش
الاكل انواع الاكل يعني ما فيش اي تغيير
تاني خالص
جدا كان 6.4 ده اللي هو الاي وان سي فايف
انت خلاص
بيغيروا حاجه في البروتين اللي جوه جسمك
تخليك مش متحس تشبع بسرعه يعني سبحان الله
سبحان الله فده عشان كده دي من الحاجات
اللي بتخليني عندي التفاؤل في اي اي
الاجابه دي هيساعدنا نلاقي ادويه احنا
زي الكوفيد يعني
نحن كنا هنجيب علاج كوفيد في اربع شهور من
غير
فعشان انا متفائل المستقبل هيبقى احسن
بكثير ان شاء الله بان الحلقه القادمه
بتكون افضل
انا اسف والله اسف
شكرا لكم شكرا لترك القحطاني في الاعداد
عبد الرحمن عبود في التصوير وحمض الحسن في
الهندسه الصوتيه عبد المجيد العباس في
التلوين ومحمد نور شمرتي التحرير واداره
التواصل الاجتماعي
نوره السبيعي وفي اداره تحرير البرنامج
اسيل بعبد الله هذا فنجان احد المنتجات
شركه 8 للنشر والتوزيع ننشر كل الانتاج
بحب من مدينه الرياض الاسبوع المقبل